[Music]
one year after starting Dr brazinsky
treatment UCLA pronounced me in
remission Dr brazinski saved my life and
for that he is facing 300 years in a
federal penitentiary perhaps Dr binski
has found the medical breakthrough of
the century certainly a wealth of
empirical data hints at that possibility
but how will we ever know if the FDA
succeeds in quashing it the FDA has
raided Dr brazinsky Clinic enough times
now that they should have been able to
prove any legitimate charges they may
have had against him the Relentless
stress the FDA has put Dr brzinsky
patients through is unforgivable the FDA
has convened four grand juries none of
which returned an indictment finally 5
days after this body pressed David
Kesler for answers on retaliatory
actions against Dr binski guess what he
was
indicted will uh fda's initiatives that
you announced today expedite the current
review of anti- neoplas on treatments I
don't want to get into any particular
agent isn't part of your problem that uh
the treatment of cancer is a very
profitable industry for a lot of
companies and that your uh treatment
right now will eat into those company's
profits
anything I'd like the following
questions to be asked the FDA how much
money have they spent in the last 10
years to try to put Dr brazinski out of
business how many documents can they
subpoena and how many more grand juries
does does he have to go to and why can't
patients who have advanced cancer seek
the medical uh treatment of their choice
the issue of whether anti-al plaston
work may not even come up during the
trial the judge says that's not relevant
you voted to acquit to AC quit
absolutely not guilty not guilty I voted
for quitt I voted my mind and my my
heart I do not believe that Dr binski is
a criminal and I had voted to
acquit binsky victory has resulted in
the American government abandoning their
initial attempt to hijack these
medicines after they filed 11 patent of
an already existing anti- neoplas on
compound by recruiting and colluding
with one of brzinsky own research
[Music]
scientists now entering a new chapter
and Against All Odds anti- neoplas on
have successfully completed a series of
Food and Drug Administration sanctioned
Phase 2 clinical trials now the therapy
is about to be tested in what's called a
phase 3 trial a massive experiment
involving potentially hundreds of brain
cancer patients worldwide Dr Stannis
brazinski is presently the first and
only scientist in United States history
to enter the federal drug approval
process for a proprietary cancer therapy
without any financial support from the
American government the pharmaceutical
industry or the cancer
[Music]
establishment as of the Year 2013 only
10% of the patients that seek brzinsky
therapy are allowed to receive anti-
neoplas on due to strictly imposed
federal government sanctions that limit
who is and who is not allowed to receive
them before we got to the clinic we
didn't know what law would be prescribed
with we were hoping she would get antop
plast on um but they did say to us we're
not going to know until you arrive and
we submit all your medical records to
the FDA they'll determine whether
they're going to approve law for
treatment or not the patients that wish
to receive anti- neoplas on are required
to go through a rigorous review process
by America's Food and Drug
Administration which generally requires
proof that chemotherapy and radiation
have first failed the patient before
being allowed access to anti- neoplans
so we got back from getting the biopsy
result and I straight away phoned the
clinic and told them what Laura's tumor
was and he said look I'm really sorry
but it's a clinical trial and there's
criteria Laura's going to have to had
radiotherapy or chemotherapy first and
fouled that I said to that's crazy what
do you mean fil that first and I said
what you know we're even we're UK
citizens does it matter that we're not
Americans do we still come under the
same law and he said yeah you'll be on
us soil when you arrive uh the clinics
on the USR we have to ad adhere to this
but we just said let's just get on with
it get on with it yeah went for the six
weeks radiotherapy I did 10 days of the
chemotherapy the temodar
and I was violently
sick even if the fda's prerequisite is
fulfilled the FDA holds full dictatorial
rights to refuse patients access to the
medicine if they choose the doctors have
told us basically there is no cure by
contrast uh Dr brazinski we have found
out has uh cured several people with
Myoma which means that this is a better
Prospect for us just St statistically
the problem is uh that the FDA in its
wisdom will not allow us to uh be
treated with the an anop plastin we have
asked the FDA what is different about my
case why I don't get an exemption we
didn't have a response yet to that to
that question they're not going to allow
uh Pat to be treated by the clinic that
has the technology to possibly save her
life upon the mapping of the human
genome dozens of new Gene targeted
medications were developed and released
by the pharmaceutical industry working
in tandem with the quickly expanding
assortment of various Gene targeted
medications constantly becoming more
available brazinsky team has been
widening their research since the 1990s
by utilizing this new technology and
thus inventing an additional technique
of cancer treatment as a brand new
alternative for his patients bra binski
defines this new technique as
personalized Gene targeted cancer
therapy in which the remaining 90% of
brzinsky cancer patients are enrolled
they are prescribed a personalized
recipe of commercial medications which
does not involve the original anti-
neoplas on
invention personalized treatment is
designed for individual patient it's
coming from understanding that cancer is
not just the single disease cancer is
perhaps perhaps half a million of
different molecular diseases this means
that every patient needs to be treated
individually if you would like to be
successful and if you like to avoid bad
adverse reactions this means that you
need to identify what is causing cancer
in theual patients and we know that
cancer is caused by abnormal genes at
this time it is necessary to identify
abnormal
genes and then it is necessary to
identify the medications which will work
on these genes
uh and use them in combination knowing
that some patients may not tolerate such
combination well again there's a way to
identify based on genomic studies if the
patients are good candidates from the
Viewpoint or adverse reactions and the
way that we do that here is by
evaluating the genetic makeup of your
cancer we've benefited from using Caris
Life Sciences Labs out in Phoenix
Arizona who will essentially do a full
genomic study of what makes your cancer
your cancer
basically they run the analysis on the
entire cancerous Genome of 24,000 genes
we are not treating for instance quote
unquote large C lung cancer we are
treating the combination of genes which
are causing this
cancer those are the S I was taking
Chris was diagnosed with stage one colon
cancer none of these commercial drugs
that the brazinski clinic prescribed him
were approved by the FDA to treat stage
one colon cancer the brazinski clinic
prescribed Chris these three medications
off label based on the findings of his
genetic profile having nothing
whatsoever to do with what these drugs
were granted Market's approval
for the my doctor called me and said
there's no
tumor can you believe have three months
it's not even less than 3 months and my
tumor was gone and just 3 months earlier
I was I was saying it was all over the
fact that we got rid of his cancer at
this time it's great okay but obviously
this would be criticized by standard
oncolog because they would say well this
patient should receive standard of care
which means surgery then combination of
chemotherapy one of the interesting
things around here is that when the drug
reps do come to present either a lunch
or or a talk about their medications
they often ask us what it is that we're
doing with their medications and they'll
gladly sit and listen
and obviously understand the mechanisms
of their medications but then they get
really perked up when we start telling
them about the other cancers that Dr
binski is freely using their medications
against every doctor we seen has said
there is no cure for meral cell cancer
yeah it's like too bad you
know might well get your papers in order
and you know pick out funeral home make
sure you got a burial plot and all this
stuff Mrs Wright was 66 years of age
when she originally consulted with me in
July of 2005 at that time she had had a
biopsy of a mass on the left side of the
face which identified Merkel cell
carcinoma in a series of five surgeries
we attempted to remove this cancer and
provide her some uh attempted cure of
her cancer we had provided good surgical
procedures for her but without lasting
result so uh we were like okay what we
do next and in our head and neck tumor
board in our Medical Center here we
decided that she would benefit by the
administration of radiation therapy and
so we went over to the radiation and so
they did a one sequence of radiation on
it and then that didn't stop it didn't
do a thing for it it was my
understanding that at that time she and
her husband did some internet work and
went online and found Dr brazinski in
Houston Texas after which time he
offered her a protocol that involved
suant sutent has not been granted Market
approval to treat Merkel cell cancer in
fact there are not any drugs granted
Market approval by the FDA to treat
Merkel cell
cancer and the tumors under here and the
tumors here and all this were gone and
part of back here they was just flat
gone I think he's out of the box and
that's what Mrs Wright needed she needed
um some fresh
ideas and um that's what has resulted in
her success is that someone took a
chance applied an off label use to a
medication that's used every day in our
cancer center but not necessarily for
this application and it has sown shown
some lasting benefit to uh Mrs writes
cancer control it's very exciting yeah
you know what's interesting is all this
stuff is not taught to you in medical
school you know the medical curriculum
that we all go through is very
traditional and they don't teach you um
they you know my medical education
taught me how to
think
but this this level of thinking goes One
Step
Beyond one of the things too about
brazinski is was the some of the first
level doctors coming from different
places different countries and learning
what he's doing Dr saana Bor works with
the prestigious University in Japan he
wants to make targeted gene therapy the
standard treatment in his country his
method is uh very
safe and uh also very
effective so I'm sure that this is the
uh new strategy of cancer
treatment the doctors here before we
left said I had to have um hospice he
was committed to a wheelchair or the bed
he could not breathe at all without
constant oxygen when we left Mark was
able to walk he had no oxygen he was a
completely stable individual he was no
longer dependent on everything he's been
on it for about a month or so and I mean
he looked completely like a different
person he was not in the wheelchair
anymore he was off his oxygen he was
walking he looked like he's gained
weight you know all the buy lymph node
that you can see from far away in his
neck where there were almost completely
gone and he just looked good and he
really felt good as well and he was not
having much really toxicity at all from
the from from that regimen in terms of
nausea vomiting low blood counts he was
just doing very very well and after we
are confident that the patient is doing
well there are no side effects and are
some initial signs of improvement the
patient can return home under the care
of the lock oncologist looking back into
into the whole thing you know I I
definitely did not recommend them to go
to the piny clinic at the beginning you
know I did not know much about it I
didn't know exactly what they were doing
over there and you know uh we we we
we're all trained in in you know in in a
certain fashion you know we follow FDA
approved chemotherapy and FDA approved
Gren uh but after I've seen what he what
he has gone through at the binski clinic
and you know the kind of response he had
I've certainly you know changed my mind
and and my opinion about it we have to
get to the point where you know
chemotherapy has to be custom made to
each patient and not one size fits
all the doctors said you know I think
this is time where we talk about do not
resuscitate papers and you know getting
them signed and I just I wanted to vomit
and before he could say anymore I just
said I've had enough I'm out of here um
my roommate um ended up knowing U one of
the people who works at the brazinsky
clinic we got an appointment and we
walked in and at this point it was in my
lungs my liver my abdomen my pelvis and
my femur bone so I was on treatment with
them from November um I guess end of
October November in December went for
scans at the end of December and we got
our Christmas miracle all my tumors were
inactive and I just I couldn't believe
it I mean my family and I were just I
mean we were left I mean we didn't even
know what to say you know we were
speechless the binski clinic prescribed
Lindsay seven different Gene targeted
medications to battle her Cancer all of
these medications are manufactured by
the pharmaceutical industry and sold to
the brazinski clinic some of the retail
prices for an annual course of these
drugs can exceed 100,00 ,000 each
insurance doesn't cover
binski since binsky technique is not
widely accepted within mainstream
oncology most insurance companies will
not cover its costs unless it is
prescribed directly from the patient
local oncologist therefore most patients
must begin therapy at the brzinsky
clinic and then return home to their
local oncologists in hopes that they
will agree and adhere to pinsky's recipe
of medications at allowing full
insurance coverage I wasn't in a
financial spot to be able to afford that
and binski Clinic tried to find
me other options um so it had a
recommendation and saw a new doctor had
agreed to follow the same regimen um
that you know do that the biny clinic
was offering me and you know get in get
in to see this doctor and she just wants
me to have chemo her thought process was
you know if you're on seven different
medicines how do you really know what it
is that's really working she thinks it's
not approved necessarily for this so why
do it you know let's go back and let's
just do strictly chemo and that's what
I'm afraid of you know going back and
saying dang it you know had we just
continued doing what we were
doing it is impossible to know for
certain if brzinsky regimen would have
saved Lindsay's life the only thing that
is certain is that Lindsay was declined
by her insurance company and her local
oncologist the opportunity to find
out if Dr brzinsky treatment is so
effective and so many of his patients
say that it is why then is it not used
here at MD Anderson one of the nation's
leading cancer hospitals simple say
doctors here it doesn't cure cancer well
I don't have any evidence as that's for
certain Dr Mari Markman is head of
research on MD Anderson his claims have
certainly not uh reached the level of uh
Acceptance in the um medical community
he says there can be lots of
explanations why certain patients
recover but to say it's because of
brzinsky treatment you can't say that he
says and if there was such proof if it
worked you'd be all over it absolutely
but Dr brazinski thinks there may be
something else at work big institutions
may not like being upstaged by an
outsider the doctor at MD Anderson
disagrees
on January 19th 2011 MD Anderson Cancer
Center announced its acceptance of a $50
million grant for cancer research
calling this grant the largest in its
history to build an entirely new cancer
research Wing called The Institute for
personalized cancer therapy which will
be created to support pre-clinical
research and clinical trials in which a
patient's tumor biopsy is assay for
abnormal genes and Gene products to
select therapy with agents targeting the
product of those particular abnormal
genes and since 2011 hardly a month has
passed without a newspaper or television
story describing this new technique
we're talking cure here we're not
talking management right if you were to
have cancer and there was someone else
your age another woman who also had the
same type of cancer that that the
reality is those are two very different
cancer still and we used a one shot
fits-all sort of approach to treat this
uh but in fact your genetic makeup your
genetic makeup and your tumor would
cause a different sort of treatment to
take place and that's where they're
focusing in on we know how to do that
already they say to map someone's genome
figure out how to treat them most
specifically for them it is unclear if
these announcements are directly due to
brazinski pioneering this method 10
years prior or if it is simply a
coincidence either way there are some
paralyzing bureaucratic roadblocks that
mainstream oncological centers like MD
Anderson have not yet faced when
announcing this new Direction namely the
firmly established 60-year-old Paradigm
of the scientifically controlled
clinical trial if I had two combinations
of pure compound neither of them by
themselves did anything significant but
you put them together and they did
something really dramatic you know but
alone they wouldn't work it is
impossible to get that approved by the f
PA because they don't know how to deal
with two things at once they want to
deal with a single pure thing they don't
have the mechanism for understanding
that in our current clinical trial
structure a university or pharmaceutical
company proposes a new cancer therapy
for Market to a regulatory government
agency in the United States this would
be the FDA the proposed therapy first
goes through a phase one trial to see if
the therapy is safe to administer if the
FDA deems it safe it graduates Ates into
a phase 2 trial which determines if the
therapy shows any efficacy if efficacy
is demonstrated it then enters a phase
three trial in a phase three trial for
advanced cancer therapies a series of
patients who all have the exact same
diagnosis are acred then split into two
groups both groups are given the exact
same established standard of care which
is generally radiation or chemotherapy
while only one group gets the newly
proposed therapy this is defined
as a randomized controlled clinical
trial if the group who received the
newly proposed therapy fares better than
the group without the FDA then releases
the therapy to the public and it becomes
a new standard of care if you were
trying to do the cocktail where you you
genetically tested people and knew that
you had four or five different drugs but
you knew that you know this subject
needs half as much of that twice as much
of that the normal amount of that la la
la and you tried to C customize this if
you tried to work that through the
current
system it just doesn't fit it doesn't
fit the Paradigm of what they're used to
working with it's so far outside I I I I
don't think it would work um I I mean I
think the treatment would work I don't
think it would work with the system I
don't think you'd be able to get that
approved it is physically impossible to
get a personalized regimen approved when
our current clinical trial structure is
based exclusively on everyone getting
the the exact same medicines each
patient would represent their own
clinical trial thus defining each
patient's outcome as merely anecdotal
and then the problem comes how to really
combine the treatments used for instance
five or six medications together if each
of these treatments is produced by
different phace companies which would
like to get rid of each other they are
not willing to cooperate with each other
you would like to put out of business
each other so that's why in the United
States would take enormous time
to bring this to surface to bring this
to approval on the other hand big
institutions big Cancer Centers uh they
are very slow they are tremendously
bureaucratic the project needs to go
from one committee to another it will
take forever to approve it and these are
small
steps many oncologist don't understand
how this medicines work for instance a
year ago we would be question why did
you use herceptin for the teatment of
stomach cancer it has been approved only
for the breast cancer but then Now
concept is approved for the teatment of
stomach cancer by the FDA why because it
works on the gene which is also involved
in stomach cancer not in everybody but
in good number of patients so what we
use for instance a year ago was right so
that's a very difficult task for most
they don't understand they treat the
name of the caner they still don't
understand the cancer is caused by the
gene if they would understand that they
have a lot of things available to treat
patients successfully this would
completely change the Outlook of cancer
treatment you may have much more
effective treatment now okay without
waiting for 30 years whatever with the
available resources they can already
save the life of numerous
patient a glioblastoma multii is a
highly malignant primary brain tumor
which in the vast majority of patients
is fatal it is
incurable in almost every patient the
doctors were very shocked because um the
biopsy revealed Laura's tumor had
progressed from a grade one or two to
now be a grade four glioblastoma
multi most of us would consider the
average survival to be about 9 to 12
months after diagnosis with with what is
termed conventional treatment and
conventional treatment consists of
surgery radiation therapy and
chemotherapy so we then knew at that
stage from this meeting that we were in
this category of this is terminal and
Laura may not have many months um yeah
months rather even not even a year I
don't know he was like 16 months old I
tried to detach myself a lot from Jacob
and my family and try and go into my own
little world I tried to tried to break
up with me she said that um you need to
have a you need to meet someone else
move on
and
um start like a family with someone else
and be with someone who's not ill you
know like someone who's not got
something like this
um
teide has given us a further weapon weon
in our fight against G blastoma by
affording patients some extra survival
though this is not been uh proven to be
scientifically significant she refused
to touch it I remember it came in a big
bag and um every night I used to have to
open the packets and and give her the
tablets and it was like a little ritual
and we both sat there and we just we
were just so against it because we knew
how ineffective it was as well mhm so it
was almost like it's making a really
sick some people don't survive
chemotherapy what's the point in Laura's
last days being in such pain and being
so ill yeah for for not much benefit you
know once conventional treatments failed
to stop Laura's gleo blastoma brain
tumor from growing they were now
released to try the brazinski
clinic a young mother from K who's
suffering from a rare form of brain
cancer is trying to raise money for
treatment which could save her life
24-year-old Laura heims from has been
told that her cancer is incurable but
she believes a new treatment which is
available in America could give her a
hope of survival it was on Christmas Eve
Laura heus was told she had a rare form
of brain cancer and the doctors have
told her there's no cure this gray patch
is a lowgrade cancer which is affecting
her balance and her coordination but
doctors are much more concerned by this
small white area which is an aggressive
form of cancer and has appeared in just
the last 3
months their research LED them to a
hospital in America which claims many
successes but is still being tried and
for this reason it's not available on
the NHS Laura must now raise £75,000
each day that goes
by you just wake up
and
sorry
just seeing my son get older every
day it's just really hard because I
think well how long have I
got Laura and Ben know that a cure is
not guaranteed but they're determined to
raise this money if it means there is at
least some hope of prolonging Laura's
life yeah there's like a lot of websites
call him a scammer a quack and the first
thing I thought was well I don't believe
everything I read so I need to find out
what this is all about so I did some
research and found a family in England
that had used this doctor and he told us
all about his experience at the clinic
gave us lots of contact details and
phone numbers I'd read for days and days
and days about Dr
bazinsky I'd sit there for hours and
hours reading message boards with
arguments going back and forth and to
find someone who'd actually been there
to not verify it it was that was it for
us even like Laura's parents and some of
my friends were saying you know this
guy's a quack when I first heard about
it I didn't think it would work because
we'd been told that the only outcome was
probably 12 months at the best and you
hear so many stories about what they
call snake doctors or pedaling medicine
that um is absolutely useless and I took
a lot of convincing
many months many
months before leaving for Houston Laura
Ben and her parents decided to have
another meeting with her oncologist to
make sure England's national Health
Service would continue to cover Laura's
MRI scans blood work and other medical
Necessities once they returned home to
England I knew it would be a very
interesting conversation because we knew
he was against what we were doing what
we decided so I decided to recall the
meeting just so that we could refer back
to to it and listen to it when we got
home because whenever we went to
oncology meetings we'd feel like we
Bamboozled like thrown so much
information that you came out and in
shock and you didn't remember half of
what was
said for legal reasons we cannot
disclose the name of Laura's oncologist
or the hospital that this meeting took
place are you hey hello hello recognize
you because I recognize your trendly
hairy hi Laura hi
hello dead Ben
Ben
yeah um I just wanted to go over what we
talked about before binski and you said
that you wouldn't trade me after if I no
no no no let's make it very clear Dr
binski is a person who provides private
care in a nonconventional way that we do
not quite understand or would condone
what the epigenetic side of it or just a
lot of it it's just not of his antinal
plon approach which is still
controversial to say the least I've had
patients there who got them cocktails of
medication that could have a rational to
work in brain tumors patients but I've
never been tried and tested in this
excessive combination you just get
antineoplastons in the clinical trial if
you don't fit the criteria then you get
personalized treatment which is what you
all discussing yeah that's what my
patients usually got at the end of the
day for is the trial yeah but this is a
trial that is currently not supported by
the NHS or the hospital so if you're
under the care there and participate in
the trials and they want to have regular
blood tests Etc and scans in accordance
with the clinical trial protocol they
need to organize for you the plot test
and the clinical trial requirements well
they they said we need to make sure
we've got a doctor here yes the beid is
that if you're on Dr binski which is not
part of the NHS practice you cannot
expect the NHS ass such to pick up the
cost associated with that would
appreciated was more more advice than I
mean for example like obviously Laura's
care here is palive when yeah not
Curative what we probably would
appreciated was more of a point in the
right direction rather than a don't go
there you know well no what I said is
that that's entirely OB to because I
know that I'm not able in a position to
prove you that I can offer you Curative
treatment in the long term I mean he
even says he doesn't claim secure no he
doesn't well but his treatment has got
very little side effects and you know at
the end of the day if this is Pala and
longterm is not a good outlook that help
you yeah you know when she comes back is
the care when she comes back regular M
blood test because this is not a trial
that is currently ethically reviewed or
approved in any of the UK institutions
here and I'm just saying that in the
conventional medical terms here may find
these clinical trials not possibly quite
as positive or as sort of supportable I
mean what what other options could be
offered because at the end of the day
this is the option Laura wants to take
and we would obviously really like you
support that well given that I'm
personally not entirely convinced that
this is a read that as an NHS oncologist
and that's my limitations
we're looking at treating Laura in a
different way so yeah and you
have TR that Laura won't be a longterm
Survivor so therefore Laura's got a
child and whether she had a child or not
it's in her interest to live as long a
life yeah Laura came home and told me
that you told her don't be bothering to
put into your pension pot so basically
you were reiterating what you told us in
the first place anyway that the
long-term survival of Laura will be very
debatable correct so as a family we look
on it quite right if it was happening to
you or your child or anyone in your
family naturally we think right well the
National Health Service unfortunately
won't be able to cure correct our
doctor's tumor in the long term correct
they can only hold it back so what is
wrong in Laura and her family seeking
hope elsewhere and it is SDA approved if
it was a quack total quack he wouldn't
have FDA
approv completely hear what you say what
say it's unethical and stuff like I do
think that's probably misleading because
at the end of day he's got here to strip
protocols to very to be in these TRS
especially to be in phase three for
other particular type of cancer and I
think his results are amazing from what
we've seen compared to the carcinogenic
treatment that you're going to get in
here you know no offense
but if one
over
don't was why that you stated if she
goes out to America yeah has the full
treatment and then comes back what I
cannot support Laura with at that point
if she is under the clinical trial under
Dr binski even though I appre FDA
approved and that's a difficult thing to
understand why I may not be quite but as
long as he's under his care his medical
Direction and he manages her then I
wouldn't be able to provide
care the primary care trust commissioned
you to provide their 8 we MRI scans of
blood test which they'll provide you
with what they need results wise and
also to do a physical health check of
law every month I don't see why then
couldn't provide that provision of care
if the PCT have agreed to pay
you
I don't see the understand because we've
got a friend who's been to the clinic
two three years ago she was here
Wednesday and she's under your care
she's been to the clinic she's an expen
patient and she's had great results she
was given three months when she was
seven and now she's 11 she's back at
school you know so that for us is a
positive thing to think about but also
it's an individual you know we
understand that but what I'm saying is
while she was at the clinic she stayed
there for two or 3 months came back to
England and she had NHS doctor doing all
those things for her here so there is a
case where it's happened for someone
else there isn't any consisteny if if it
can have we request I I personally have
a problem with Dr binski and the
individual care plans that he's been
delivering and if you just into the
clinical trial just to get the anop
plast on that may be a slightly
different bit so you wouldn't see a
problem with a clinical trial we're just
asking for the basic she should be able
to have that care I'm not very happy
with personally you can understand from
ourside what we're saying is you're
delivering palet of care to Laura we
found something which in trial I
understand you don't believe or you know
whatever you're on views we want to do
that dream we'll pay for it so I can't
see why you would have a problem with
that we we do differ in our
understanding what is a problem or not a
problem and well I'm very happy to
support Laura to get everything she
needs there are a few things that I
personally would not support and as I
said direct taking advice from Dr binsky
but what is needed and required is one
of the few things where I personally me
as a person he'll send you a sheet once
a month and he'll say can she walk yes
it's a physical check the other ones are
Bloods taken every two weeks you'll get
the blood results which you then fax to
the clinic we're just ordinary
run-of-the-mill people but we're all the
same no one's better than anybody else
and all Laura wants to do is live as
long as she can cuz you
know understand with those facts why you
wouldn't in this circumstance go outside
of perhaps your comfort zone or beliefs
to help Laura achieve what she wants to
do as a human being yeah he can't help
everyone some people go there on their
last legs and he can't he can't help
them and they died you expect me to
respect your choice but we're giving you
a very good argument why that's our
choice but I don't feel that you're
giving us a very good argument back
about why that's your choice she may get
sad news out in America if if she
doesn't respond to the antio plason but
we want her to to have that chance well
if so this did work and you know you
were helping Laura achieve that by
giving her the care here wouldn't that
be a major positive thing for the
medical community I don't know I mean
I'm just trying to understand that's why
you do these trials in the US it is FDA
approved I know so that must you know we
are supposed to be friends with America
when would you need to start
if there's progression on the next scan
we can start straight away if there's no
progression we have to wait a further
four weeks okay you can't cure Laura in
the long run that's the only way we're
looking at it is a family if we knew
that Laura could be cured we wouldn't be
looking elsewhere Laur would have been
costing the nhsx amount of money because
of conventional chemotherapy treatments
St let me know when you need to have
your
scan yeah you can have a CD ROM or that
diagnostic image yeah once Laura goes
out to America and she's all set up it
would be fantastic if look after Laura
when she's back in in this country so
obviously we've got no other choice this
is what we're doing okay so with that
with your position are you are you going
to try very hard would you like to do it
for Laura putting the side the brazinski
clinic would you like to help Laura that
is not the question yeah well but that
is you took the hypocritic oath as a as
an oncologist or as a doctor before you
train okay I think we've done what we
can do at the moment okay I'll check you
can keep those I'll check on those off
again I don't think we finished you're
the top consultant that we can talk to
so we need to know what the the normally
is at the moment to finish the
radiotherapy has planned and then we
normally would only follow you up on
clinical grounds on once about every 3
months basis you know I'd be on Watch
and wait after when when it starts to
get big again what would you do then
surgery radiotherapy is most unlikely to
be suitable option at the time or
further chemotherapy would they be very
effective none of the chemotherapies
that is available at the moment is
long-term effective so in a way I mean
for this it's is not really an option I
just think everyone needs at the moment
to time out because I think we're not
really making any progress if it it's
about her I mean that's great and then
as a as a personal opinion you a
person thank
you it was a very bad time and it's left
us with a very distrusting attitude of
the National Health Service and when you
mention to them options they just shake
their heads no no that's not going to
work yeah we we just feel
very what the hell is going on in this
world there were a lot of newspapers and
magazines clambering for our story but
when these stories were printed it was
exactly the story we wanted but the
headline was how am I going to tell my
son I'm going to die it's just you know
I don't know how these people can sleep
at night printing these kind of stories
when we decided to go to the bazinsky
clinic and start fundraising I emailed
Ben at work and said I've had an idea I
want to start up a fundraising campaign
and website and call it the hope for
Laura fund a wellknown comedian read our
website someone tweeted it to him on
Twitter and he was so taken with it that
he did a video that was about 4 minutes
long hello you lot on Twitter this young
M with a 19-month-old son needs 80 grand
uh to go to America for a years worth of
treatment I I don't know uh what we can
do but there's uh there's information
about how we can donate on uh hope forur
fund. co.uk I've got 200,000 followers
that means if if only one in five gave a
couple of quid then this afternoon we we
could have saved a woman's life a young
mom's life and uh we got 25,000 that day
um and in the weeks following that more
money just kept coming in we raised
£75,000 in 5 weeks which is what we
needed for years treatment
yeah this interview with Laura and Ben
took place on March 3rd
2012 435 days since Laura's original
diagnosis and 228 days since beginning
anti- neoplas on therapy 11 days before
this interview an independently
conducted MRI by her local radiologist
reveals Laura's tumor to have diminished
by
77% um basically I was
trained by the doctors in America
to just look after all of this for Laura
it does make the routines in the day a
bit difficult cuz there's a dose every 4
hours these were new last night these
bags and this one lasts for a whole 24
hours that one only lasts a half a day
cuz you can see it's empty now she's
done three doses out of that
overnight so now I've got to change this
bag just that
one this new bag the A10
after a whole year of doing this day in
day out I mean Laura's had probably 2
and 1 half th000 doses there's only
three doses in there you can imagine how
many bag changes there been so bag one
takes an hour and 20 minutes to deliver
a whole dose so these work on a 4our
cycle that's it just get it all back
together I mean this is relaxing for me
like knowing I'm actually doing
something rather than sitting around
watching a try and get better I'm
actually helping her I think one of the
biggest things for me was the fact that
I went over there with her and I took
part in
this you stand it's actually easier
to have it
under press start this will go green
that basically means it's going to start
in one
minute other people contacted us you
know like their husband or son or
someone may have the same type of tumor
as Laura asking for information and with
the same questions we had you know is
this guy a quack what's all this what's
it all about you know and we just say to
them look you've got to do a lot of
research read between the lines make
your own mind up if you decide it's not
for you then don't do it back in
September last year I got an email out
of the blue from a guy called Pete Cohen
and uh and we had a chat and um he told
me about his girlfriend Hannah I was
rushed to hospital they thought I might
have had a stroke and all manner of
things meningitis everything um and I
was sent down for a scan and it showed a
darkening on one area of my brain and
then they advised me that I had a brain
tumor he got most of the tumor out with
Hannah talking moving and convering
normally it wasn't that scary I can
remember everything laughing and joking
with the nurses the speech
therapist but anyway I still had a brain
tumor when I came out most of the tumors
we know that millions of cells remain in
the brain and they can be very very
aggressive in a way we are providing a
setting for a second stage therapy to
take place I started the my radio
therapy course around May and that went
on to Mid June um and then I went for
another
scan about 6 to 8 weeks afterwards and
there was still tumor left we looked at
lots of options um the doctors are very
limited um
options I they didn't offer me
chemotherapy at that point in time I'm
sure it would have got to that um but we
wanted to find something different they
came over here in December and met us
for the first time um just a week before
they flew to America there was so many
obstacles in getting her over there
obviously the biggest one being the FDA
deciding that somewhere somewhere in
America someone looked at her case and
decided yes or no thankfully they said
yes but they could have said no yeah
maybe we had a good guy in on the maybe
flipped a coin just hey heads up we're
in hi Daddy hello how are you yeah I'm
sorry for ringing so late that's right
um but I'm ringing with really really
good news good that's what I want to
hear go you no you tell her I don't
think I
can tell
me come on my
tumor yeah has already shrunk by
10% you're [__] hell
man
[__] that is
Absol
amazing this interview took place on
March 2nd 2012 19 days later an
independently conducted MRI by Hannah's
local radiologist revealed that Hannah's
tumor diminished by
63% things are great Laura's been on
treatment for 13
months and after 9 months the tumor
[Music]
disappeared and she's been on the
maintenance program since then which
basically means 8 months of treatment
from the time the tumor disappeared
until she can finish and that's to get
rid of everything else that maybe isn't
on the scans showing
[Music]
up
I should finish just after Christmas so
that'll be exactly 2 years since
diagnosis that I've been fighting this
thing because I was diagnosed on
Christmas
Eve and Jacob is only 16 months old at
the
time
I've got so much more
energy I'm just I'm able to get up and
down the stairs simple things like that
just do normal things like cooking yeah
going out like Laurel was at home for
months without going out anywhere um
it's like it's slowly brought me out of
this dark hole there was a point in time
where even if I talked about doing
something next week with Laura or
whatever just making any kind of plan
she'd feel really angry and refused to
live for the future just for today and
right now but then she started slowly
over time thinking about like next week
the week
after and like we've plannned our
wedding now which is next year so we're
thinking about the future without
worrying so
much just on a purely human
nothing to do with medical I just I felt
absolutely gutted devastated for her the
thought of having such a horrendous
thing and then being told basically
there's nothing anyone could do and
going out doing all the research so
meticulously and becoming so
knowledgeable about all of it I I'm
speechless guys I think it's ex children
me do you feel uneasy or uncomfortable
at all because of the fact that it is
experimental and it's quite
controversial no I mean it's out of I
suppose it's out of my comfort zone to
be dealing with something that I haven't
really got a grip on I don't understand
and in terms of do I mind that it's a
controversial thing not not at all not
at all um you know I this is a desperate
situation you do what you have to do if
you've got the drive to do
it she's always going to be having scans
for the rest of her life but probably
more less frequent
but we can kind of stop letting it rule
Our Lives Jacob how are you doing
today not too
bad I think when you were last here I
said um something
like we're just taking each day as it
comes and now I kind of can plan in
advance a bit more I mean cuz you feel
so different now right I mean look at
that smile I mean you know she's
optimistic about life she's thinking
about tomorrow and the next day Hannah's
had um a complete response should be on
the treatment now for another well it's
now it'll be seven months so seven more
months of this and then hopefully well
being well that's it she's off stop and
she can yeah move around and and start
living a normal life again which a year
ago seemed impossible that wasn't going
to yeah that it was a dream oh it was a
dream we wanted it but I think you
probably believed it less I probably
believed more that what we were going to
do was going to
work I treat many patients with brain
stem gomas and brain stem Goma is also a
very
unpleasant fatal in almost every case
brain primary brain tumor and a brain
stem Goma in a child is by and large a
death
sentence various treatments have been
utilized over uh the world
sadly nothing has been found to
be effective over a long period of time
in any significant group of patients
it's a devilish and you know desperately
awful disease to be suffering from brain
stem gomas are a blanket term for tumors
occurring in the brain stem brain stem
gomas are found in children more often
than adults 85% of them occur in the P
region and are defined as a
dipg or diffuse intrinsic pontine
glya the doctors were saying I think
they're being kind to me they were
saying oh there might be a 15% chance
that she'll survive so you cling on to
that 15% but the more and more research
you do you think no what are they
talking about there isn't a 15% survival
rate for this dipg she's going to die
there's no known survivors the only
survivors we could find came back to the
bazinsky clinic so for me it was a
no-brainer we either do this or do
nothing it was good to talk to other
people I think I talked to um um Ben and
Laura because they were out there a few
weeks before we were going and it's just
reassuring to hear from someone else
from your own country look actually this
is good it's fine and we got there the
doctors were brilliant having gone
through all my treatment with breast
cancer I'd met plenty of doctors so you
kind of know who's a good doctor and
who's a bad doctor after meeting so many
so as soon as we got there we thought
thought right okay this is definitely
the right right thing to do and we were
treated brilliantly and when we met Dr
bazinsky the first thing he said to us
was it doesn't work for everyone and
we're working on trying to find out the
reasons why it works for some and not
for others and he said unfortunately
kids who haven't had
radiotherapy do tend to do a little
better better but we didn't have any
choice Billy was going downhill so
rapidly she had to have radiotherapy and
I'm really happy
that um given the outcome unfortunately
Billy didn't make it but it's a lot
easier to deal with knowing that we did
absolutely everything possible to try
and save her when you speak to other
parents you are in this kind of club the
dipg club unfortunately it's horrible
place to be but you learn so much and
you get far better feedback and advice
from other families than you do from
doctors so you do form very strong
friendships you do feel like you're all
in it together and you give each other a
lot of support and there's no [__]
because who's going to lie or [__]
to you when they're in the same
situation with their kid so I wanted to
pass that on to other families so when
Richard Saunders got in touch with me
about Amelia saying this has happened to
us what would you do he was I I think
really on the edge of deciding well
maybe we do nothing because that's what
the doctors have said and I felt it
really important to encourage him to at
least consider bazinsky because I
definitely feel it was the right thing
for us to do so I'm really pleased that
they went ahead and fingers crossed for
them we met 4-year-old Amelia Saunders
and her parents in London a few weeks
after she was diagnosed with a
dipg I am the ultimate skeptic by the
way with everything and I thought these
are real cases of this thing working and
actually you know when you're given no
choice at all with
something either you try it and if it's
that 1% chance that it works you got to
give it a go because bywise we had a 0%
chance we do have a 0%
chance 6 weeks later we met the Saunders
family in America at the brazinski
clinic she's been on treatment for three
weeks she's had a couple of little
hiccups along the way but other than
that she's done really well um there's
there were no promises at all and there
have been their promises um there's been
no magic ones to say this is definitely
going to
work 5 months later we visited the
Saunders at their home at the moment we
don't know what's going on we really
don't know what um is happening in terms
of uh whether the the treatment will
actually shrink the tumor at all right
now the only thing we can sort of grasp
on to is how she's doing physically and
what the scans
show um and those scans are the same
every single time equally it's not grown
you know and that's got to be a good
thing um I have no doubt that without
the treatment it would have it would
have grown and I don't I don't actually
believe milia would be here now you know
we we've never ever regretted the
decision that we made we were told
originally that we might have a month
two months month between between a month
and three or four months I think that
was the maximum time they said to have
Amelia here now starting school is
amazing and two months after this
interview Amelia's condition began to
deteriorate and her parents decided to
discontinue anti- neoplas on therapy
Amelia passed away with her parents by
her side on January the 6th 2013
brain stem Goma is as rare as it is
deadly approximately 500 children a year
in the United States and 40 children a
year in England are diagnosed with it an
exhaustive search spanning 27 years of
all available medical literature
worldwide reveals the absence of any
patient ever being cured or living 5
years after diagnosis likewise no
proposed medication from the cancer
industry has demonstrated enough safety
and efficacy by any of the world's
Regulatory Agencies to gain Market
approval for this condition a
comprehensive 21-year study reported in
one of the world's most prestigious
oncology medical journals the Lancet
published that radiation Remains the
standard treatment chemotherapy has not
shown any benefit overall Outlook is
poor and nearly all children eventually
die most studies showed a median
survival time of shorter than one
year Tor Marino's birth on Father's day
was caused for celebration but as she
grew her parents began to notice
something unusual about her so Kim
Marino and her husband Roman took their
seven-week old baby girl to a
neurologist who told them she had an
inoperable brain tumor and wouldn't live
more than 6 weeks I mean that left us
with okay this is what we're facing with
we will come home we will bring her home
and just love her daily you know while
she's here and so Tor began taking
steroids to reduce the pressure on her
brain the drugs have left her swollen
part I remember Tories and colleges
telling me um that your daughter is
going to die I recommend that you don't
um do CPR I know you're a police officer
you guys you're part of your training
but you may want to let her die and uh I
have her desate ready to go just need
needs to be signed but they refuse to
give up hope and they sought out an
experimental gene therapy treatment
that's never been tried on someone so
young they'll leave their home in Garden
Grove this weekend for a journey that
could save their daughter's life it's
the first day of experimental gene
therapy treatment that could reduce a
large tumor in her brain the medication
will be pumped into her body six times a
day for the next 6 weeks and will
gradually increase in dosage but the
number one concern for little tor's
doctor and her parents is if there's
enough time to save her you know even if
she makes it to her first or second
birthday i''d be overjoyed Pat doctors
in Texas told baby tor's parents the
cancerous growth is so large pressing on
the baby's brain they can't believe the
little girl is able to eat or move her
arms and
legs but this little gal is quite a
fighter she is holding her own despite
being the youngest person ever to
undergo the experimental
treatment everybody this is my niece
baby
Tori Tori Moreno arrived home in La this
afternoon in Texas doctors inserted a
catheter into tor's chest through it
experimental medicine called anti- neop
plastin will be administered daily by
her parents right at home and they're
not yet sure whether it will shrink
tor's tumor she's the youngest person
ever to try the therapy
you know back uh the initial onset in
August when they were telling us that
she was going to die was I we can't even
believe she's still alive right now this
is an oncology team um three of them and
tor's pediatrician um who's been a
doctor for a long time was saying this
is the worst case had ever seen in their
history and remember that first scan
came back I think we started in October
and by December it was the first time
you get a chance to look at something
there was already a dramatic impact with
that and not only that to take those
scans to an outside doctor going okay
tor's parents took her December 1998
scans to St Francis Medical Center for a
confirmation the scan at the start of
anti- neoplas on therapy was dated
October 13th St Francis also described
tor's tumor in Greater detail noting
that it was within the ponds region
almost completely replacing it and
extending out beyond the brain stem
itself they noted the subsequent scan
dated December 10th the tumor appears to
have decreased in size they summarized
that comparisons between the October
13th and the December 10th scans
suggests an approximate 20 to 25%
decrease in the size of tor's
tumor and then a couple months later it
might have been two or three months
later we saw an additional reduction the
doctors I remember even in California uh
the oncology team was still baffled they
were still making excuses um and I was
starting to see through that clearly now
saying wow what is the the big issue
with this guy is successful and I I
almost like some professional Envy or
something like that I I go wow okay I
just was just baffled at at the way they
weren't giving Dr brzinsky uh all this
credit for this and they were talking
about spontaneous remissions and I go
like what I've already done the homework
with that spontaneous remissions and a
brain syoma those don't happen and I
said do you know who Dr binsky is well
I've heard of him and I said he in
Houston Texas he deals with antop plas
well I don't really know much about it I
remember talking to the doctors going
well I am a police officer I don't save
lives for a living and I know a lot
about it my suggestion is that you do
some research with this Dr brazinsky I
was baffled that they didn't take some
time to get to know this doctor that was
saving lives in Houston Texas um but um
as we continued to go through there we
saw you know an ability for Tori to
possibly live we didn't feel like we're
even out of the woodwork no one came
will this stuff shut off will it stop
working and so it wasn't till about
maybe 6 months into it that we started
feeling comfortable like our daughters
they get chance to live here she is
celebrating her we've had 14 birthdays
now with her when they were saying you
know she wouldn't make it to her first
so um unfortunately I obviously was too
young to remember any of it but I just
when people ask me that I unfortunately
don't have a lot of information get them
but it's
um I just I just it's my story it's part
of me it's madebe who I am I just I
think it's a really really cool
story a 2006 scientifically
peer-reviewed report published in
pediatric drugs reported the results of
two Phase 2 anti- neoplas on clinical
trials for children with diffuse brain
stem Goma a a total of 40 children were
treated and an average of 25% of them
lived Beyond 5 years while competing
Phase 2 and phase 3 clinical trials
using a combination of radiation and
standard chemotherapy showed zero
survivors in 2012 America's National
Cancer Institute likewise began publicly
citing and acknowledging one of the
phase 2 peer-reviewed anti- neoplas on
clinical trials for brain stem Goma
as of 2013 there have only been two
medications to ever be approved by the
FDA for malignant brain tumors temodar
in 1999 and aastan in 2009 though
neither of them demonstrated enough
safety or efficacy to reach FDA approval
for a brain stem Goma nor were either of
these drugs required to enter a
multi-center randomized phase 3 trial
before being FDA approved approved for
Market this was made possible due to
legislation released in the 1990s when
the FDA formed its accelerated approval
program to quickly approve drugs that
serve as the first available treatments
for a life-threatening condition instead
of requiring evidence of clinical
benefits such as survival FDA will rely
on objective evidence of partial
response such as tumor shrinkage as an
initial basis for approval this will
allow us to rely on smaller shorter
studies for the initial approval of
cancer drugs temodar first received
accelerated approval for anaplastic
astrocytoma brain cancer based on a
single arm Phase 2 study of 54 patients
12 of the patients responded with five
of these patients having a complete
response though the overall survival
time was 15.9 months at the time of
approval no results were available from
randomized controlled trials to show any
clinical benefit or prolonged survival
aastan was granted accelerated approval
for gleo blastoma brain cancer based on
two single arm Phase 2 trials the first
was a phase 2 randomized study of
patients who had tried and failed
temodar and radiation in this single
randomized study some responses were
observed in 25.9% of the patient with
the average response itself lasting
about 4.2 months there was also a single
arm Phase 2 study conducted using 56
patients all of whom also tried and
failed temodar and radiation 19.6% of
these patients responded with the
average response lasting about 3.9
months so the only two drugs to ever be
approved for malignant brain tumors were
never required to enter a traditional
multi- Center randomized phase 3 trial
before reaching approval nor was either
drug required to cure a single patient
these drugs were however required to
enter a multicenter randomized phase 3
trial only after they were already in
the hands of the public comparably a
series of multiple single arm FDA
sanctioned Phase 2 clinical trials for
brain stem Goma using anti- neoplas on
conducted from 1995 to 2008
169 patients in total were treated with
33 of those patients being completely
cured or have lived Beyond 5
years anti- neop plaston are more than
qualified for Accelerated approval to
serve as the first available effective
treatment for brain stem Goma instead
the FDA has mandated that anti- neoplans
be the first and only exception in FDA
history where an effective life-saving
first available cancer medicine will not
be granted the option for Accelerated
approval in 2011 over 7,000 Americans
signed a petition with President Obama's
administration asking Congress to
intervene in this matter the White House
did not respond instead the FDA
responded stating that no randomized
controlled studies showing the
effectiveness of anti- neoplans have
been published nor have all the trials
needed to approve anti- neoplas been
conducted however 3 years prior the FDA
officially acknowledged that anti-
neoplas demonstrated enough safety and
efficacy in Phase 2 trials thus granting
permission to proceed into phase 3
randomized trials for brain stem
Goma it is difficult to verify the
rationale for the fda's insistence on
antineoplastons being subjected to phase
3 trials for brain stem Goma but some
theorize that this rare exception is due
to the pharmaceutical industry having
too much power over the FDA and is
directly preventing
antineoplastons from Gaining Market
approval of any kind Dr David Graham has
been working at the FDA for 20 years
he's a senior official we sat down with
Dr Graham for his first extended
face-to-face television interview just
who is the FDA working for a former
manager of mine in the office of drug
safety told me that industry was our
client and when I said to him no the
public is my client he said I was wrong
that it was industry FDA is there to
serve its client industry it is not
there to serve the public FDA has become
a factory for the approval of new drugs
to understand how the FDA got to where
it is today you need to go back to
1992 that year the first President Bush
with the support of both Democrats and
Republicans signed into law the
prescription drug user fee Act the law
was passed in response to Industry
complaints that the FDA wasn't approving
drugs fast enough part of the deal the
drug companies agreed to start paying
the FDA to speed up the approval process
it worsened a culture with an FDA that
was already bad to start with that said
we will approve drugs and we'll approve
them quickly because essentially all
this money is coming in from the
pharmaceutical companies therefore we
need to please the pharmaceutical
companies well that that is eventually
the mentality that you emerged that's
changed the whole balance of financial
power within the agency here's the thing
while the industry has been providing
more and more money for approvals
Congress has cut spending for the rest
of what the FDA does as a result almost
four out of every $5 the FDA spends on
drug regulation now goes to getting new
drugs approved for sale you I pick up
the papers and I read articles that say
that the FDA is slow in approving drugs
the big problem that you all have over
there there is bureaucratic foot
dragging keeping important new
treatments away from people who need it
desperately right that is a complaint I
think where that complaint originates
from is probably from the pharmaceutical
industry it's not true though I mean
even the cases of a drug that might be
necessary
to help someone's cancer from
progressing well let's put it this way
if you look at most drugs that get
approved on the marketplace most of them
aren't offering a true therapeutic
Advance you this whole rig roll at the
FDA to get a drug approved and you're
saying it doesn't
offer much over an existing drug no it
usually doesn't offer anything over
existing drug what let's look at Vio
what we say is the truth trust us this
drug is safe and effective it's safe and
effective because we the FDA say it is
and we don't have to produce evidence to
justify that and their reaction is
predictably and uniformly the same which
is they deny that there's a problem and
they kill the messenger who brought them
the bad
news if the FDA released anti- neoplas
on to the public to treat brain stem
Goma it would in turn also allow any
cancer patient with any type of cancer
diagnosis to also have the option to
receive anti- neoplas on from their
local oncologist under the fda's
category of all off label
use and this is this is this is a very
common kind of business practice on on
all kinds of business is you you try to
push out the competition and you know
because bringing a drug to Market takes
$400 $800
million they're going to try to minimize
any competition and that could be you
know competition can be on a lot of
levels this this is pretty normal in all
facets of business they want to remove
competition
uh in any way that they can that's legal
or maybe not quite so legal one of the
things that helps to perpetuate the
system the way that it is is you the FDA
is regulating the Pharma world but the
Pharma
world is all run by the same people the
same people who are regulating all this
big Pharma are the same people who are
running the big farma and they go back
and forth you know you start up you move
up through the FDA you become important
enough big Pharma will hire you because
you have that expertise and all the
contacts in in the agency and it goes
the other way if you're if you're in big
Pharma well you learn enough you know
how it is you got enough buddies on both
sides it's a fact there's you can just
look at records public records and and
it it's a big boys
club the FDA requires that any phase 3
trials for any new drug be conducted by
a series of independent hospitals
without the inventors involvement upon
receiving the official permission from
the FDA to begin a series of phase three
randomized clinical trials to get anti-
neoplas on approved for brain stem Goma
the binsky research institute approached
nearly every single Children's Hospital
in the United States Canada and England
and every single one of these hospitals
flatly refused to participate in these
phase three trials for brain stem Goma
cuz you know a big company like an
astroica or what they put a lot of money
into companies like the quintiles and
and and other contract research
organizations that feed into these if
you don't think they have an influence
on what kind of business those
businesses will pick up cuz you know if
you're going to work with him I'll move
my work somewhere else a common reason
some of the hospitals gave after
rejecting this study was simply not
interested other hospitals denied
participation because they didn't like
the idea that patients would take the
therapy home with them undergoing
24-hour infusions carrying an electric
pump around and changing their bags on
their own since every other standard of
care therapy has always been
administered for its full duration
within the hospital itself another
reason all hospitals refused to
participate was out of fear that no
parent would agree to allow their child
to enter one of these phase 3 trials
because the FDA has also mandated that
radiation therapy be required in both
groups since radiation is proven to
cause serious debilitating side effects
when administered to the brain stem
region of a developing child the Lancet
oncology 2006 expose on childhood brain
stem Goma has pointed out that
theoretically randomized studies are the
method of choice to test a new
hypothesis however when the standard
treatment or control group provides no
chance of success the rationale to have
a randomized design with a stand
standard treatment group is questionable
and practically very difficult
especially in pediatric or children's
oncology the best method remains to be
defined another reason is due to the
reputation of the therapies inventor who
has legally defeated the FDA itself in
five Federal grand juries and two sets
of juried federal
trials when you add all of these reasons
up it becomes easy to understand why no
hospital will step out on a limb to
participate in these trials since any
prospective patient doing a Google
search for anti- neoplas on or its
inventor is met with a slew of
negativity the same is true if any
current past or future patient posts
anything on Facebook or Twitter they are
instantly met with an onslaught of
harassment and intimidation that has
been carefully crafted and executed by a
well organized International
[Music]
Group
who call themselves The
Skeptics they're hidden behind that
keyboard so they can say whatever they
like and they're probably paid by the
Pharmaceuticals and I'm sure they're in
Hawk with uh with the governments with
people that you know make a living out
of being Skeptics to keep everything
suppressed you can't dare up the truth
come out because that would be because
it would cost the government too much
money yeah I've been working uh for the
last couple of months with some fairly
big names in the skeptical movement and
people you'd be surprised who'd be
working on the same team to combine
forces uh legal teams and budgets and
we're going to bring uh brazinski a
present on his um on his birthday oh are
the FDA needs to to step up and stop
participating in this transparent on
goinging scam um by no longer approving
patients who want to participate in his
unpromising imaginary trials people who
want to step up and protect these
patients can do something very very
important and that's right about this
man and about his Clinic uh and his
treatment anti-neoplastic we need to
saturate the normal channels by which
people come to him with better
information and I can't think of a
better reason to do it than to see that
brazinski is uh widely exposed and
ridiculed as as the uh uh uh
unproven um kind of uh quack that he is
quite frankly when you talk about people
at their last ditch efforts to fight
cancer especially
children it's really difficult not to
look like a a heartless cynical skeptic
I know it doesn't sound good to the
people who are there right now they they
are funding his future campaigns of
deception
and and that's what we're trying to stop
my time is better spent warning the
people who don't believe yet and the
people who are you know in Bin's Camp
can stay in his camp and I'm not going
to try to dissuade them but I am going
to try to dissuade him from recruiting
any more customers absolutely absolutely
he's going to be hearing from us to
Polish sausage
[Laughter]
you when we met Dr bazinsky he is
without shadow of a doubt one of the
kindest this is ridiculous all these
people in the world that think this man
is a crook or a charlatan they don't
really know what's going on they haven't
looked into it they've just heard or
read something
you know we spent seven weeks there yeah
and if that guy's a fraud then he's the
biggest fraud it's the biggest scam
ever and there is a really strange
relationship that he has with his
patients um it it's almost a fanatical
uh Devotion to him above all reason
something that you see a lot in Cults um
what a cult does it brings people in and
makes them dependent on the cult for
something
and you see that being repeated over and
over and over in the patient
testimonials uh there's a seriously
called a personality around the leader
uh it really does feel a lot like a sort
of death
cult we've had some therapy because of
everything we've been through
understandably everyone would you know
when I started my side of the therapy on
my own I I was actually quite shocked to
find that everything I was talking about
like how stressed I was and just how I
couldn't switch off all the time was all
to do with the fundraising and the
stress of trying to raise money while
people were trying to stop us raise
money and I think the most one of the
most stressful things obviously apart
from Lura being being ill with cancer
the second most stressful thing was
trying to deal with all this criticism
really I mean it's come close to
like tearing Our Lives apart to be
honest we've had an 18mon old son to
look after and we got these people
basically telling Laura she should just
die forget choosing yeah one actually
did say that as well or wrote it in in a
message Bard um that I should just
accept that I'm going to
die uh brazinski adopts none of the
risks that any other researcher adopts
charging terminal patients
upfront a common skeptic criticism of
the brazinski clinic is charging money
for the therapy upfront before the
treatment begins since insurance
companies generally refuse to pay for it
we end up getting our insurance company
to pay I can't mention the name of the
insurance company because we end up were
forced to sign a gag order brinsky staff
was paid you know under the table when
we had ass signed this gag order I'm
thinking wow they they're going through
all these steps to sit there and have to
conceal that what that they're paying
for something that they're got forced to
pay for to maybe save a kid
in 2008 the Wall Street Journal
published an expose explaining how
nonprofit hospitals such as MD Anderson
Cancer Center asked one patient for
$15,000 in cash before admitting her MD
Anderson's Vice President of Finance
said asking patients to pay after
they've received a treatment is like
asking someone to pay for a car after
they've driven off the lot um you see a
lot of people saying well the reason why
he can't do his trials is because cost
$200 million to do a trial I don't know
where they're getting that number and
that um you know he's not getting any
external funding so he has to charge
people out the nose um and that's just
not how it works it's really difficult
for people to understand about paying
for something yourself so when we found
out how much the binsky treatment was
yes it's a lot of money but if you put
it into context of chemotherapy we met
someone at a clinic in Texas whose
daughter was having
chemotherapy and their medical bill
which was covered by their medical
insurance fortunately was
$800,000 for the month so when you think
that the bazinsky treatment is $10,000 a
months or less then it's relatively
cheap but it's just difficult for people
to get their heads around actually
paying out of your own pocket the
Skeptics have hijacked and locked the
Wikipedia p page on the brzinsky clinic
blocking all neutral contributions in
their efforts to sway any prospective
patients from considering this therapy
the only neutral information found in
this entry is brzinsky date of birth and
prior medical
education the skeptic responsible for
this article also compiles and publishes
death lists of previous
[Music]
patients most all of whom were children
who died of brain stem Goma he then
republishes the lists on various
websites giving the illusion that they
are coming from more than one
source this skeptic receives funding
from America's Department of Defense the
National Cancer Institute the American
Society for clinical oncology the breast
cancer research foundation and the
pharmaceutical industry in another of
his paid positions for a National
Geographic syndicated blog this writer
uses a different name and publishes
articles about patients undergoing anti-
neoplas on treatment and the therapy
itself on a near weekly basis in um
October when we released uh stable
results we put two scans up we put
September and October up it's the same
size but it started to break down a bit
so we were happy we put these scan
pictures up on our website the next 6
weeks later we did another scan and it
trunk 36% so we told everyone this news
released on our website he then did an
article and using a link to the previous
scans as his evidence saying look at
these scans it's clearly not
shrunk you
know he's lying to
them
we've got a message for any people that
have been disrespectful to
me try to try to stop people yeah try to
stop people donating to me to help me
get better so I can see my sun grow up I
want to tell you all basically stick
your noses out of our business yeah and
[__] off and [__] off
now that dozens of successful anti-
neoplas on Phase 2 trials are complete
it is the responsibility of the inventor
to publish the details of those trials
in the peer-reviewed medical literature
allowing it to be shared globally with
the scientific Community up until 2006
articles containing anti- neoplas on
studies have been consistently accepted
in various medical journals
on November 26th
2012 an anti- neoplan Phase 2 study
regarding patients who lived between 8
to 16 years after being diagnosed with a
gleo blastoma multiform the same type of
incurable brain tumor Laura heus
had was rejected by the Lancet
oncology 2 hours after it was
submitted the reason for the lancet's
rejection was simply we have decided not
to publish it because we believe the
message would be better
elsewhere the most common argument from
medical scientists who dismiss all cases
of people cured using an anti- neoplas
on as being merely anecdotal comes from
the absence of any randomized controlled
clinical
trials
science must be born in
doubt an anecdotal
event produ a scientific
mind anecdotal is very important but if
you report anecdotal anecdotal
anecdotal doesn't do anything good it's
not
persuing it's not convincing that's why
we we did the randomiz
study the motivation why we started this
research on anti paston for the last 27
years we did not believe Dr binski
blindly would like to see very much the
effect of of an plasm by our own eyes in
our own ways we did the phase one study
first we would like to know that how
much dose the patient could tolerate we
use antino blaston A10 and as2 D1
injection formula and uh oral formula in
the 43 patient about 50% of patient are
responding to
this combination therapy with antino
blastin 18 and
as21 we published this result from the
phase one clinical study since we found
the better response in the cancer of the
liver we decided to concentrate our
study on Li cancer study and uh we move
our research to phase two clinical trial
we found the as2 d r could obviously
prolong disease free interval and
overall
survival so we mve to the prospective
randomized clinical trial in this study
we subjected the liver metastasis from
colum we divided the patient into two
groups randomly in controlled and antop
treated group 30 patient in antinone
group and 33 patient in control group
and the in antinone group we add a
antinas A10 injection for one week as-1
capsule for at least one year in
addition to the intraarterial hepatic
infusion 5 Fu in control group The about
50% of the patient live the around 36
months
in antias group 50% of the patient lives
about 70 months so it's you know
obviously the ant makes it longer about
double the scientific Community invented
the randomized study
for not only excluded the anex
data they are avoiding the bias this has
been done in Kur University Hospital uh
completely independent from any other
Institute or we are not uh
given advice from binski either this is
the way the the scientist should be
without first without the data from the
binski and we tested it we found that
the Dr binski was right it it's not
obviously anecdotal
[Music]
anymore
if cancer was cured today there's a lot
of Institutions around the US especially
our universities but also in the Pharma
industry that would all of a sudden lose
a lot of money and and with the NIH the
university gets matching funds to to
keep the buildings and all the other
things that so universities especially
that are into cancer research they don't
really have an incentive to find that
cure because then it all dries up as
much as you you know may not like that
that's the way our system is it's not
the Star Trek world where if What You
Need Is What You Get and la la la but it
is reality and money wins money votes
money does everything and it controls
our government as much as we hate to
admit it it uh motivates the
pharmaceutical industry we're not out in
the Pharma world as the commercials will
tell you that we're out there to make
everybody healthy and happy and that's
not why they're out there they're
they're there to make money period the
best drugs in the Pharma world are the
ones that people have to continue taking
forever and ever and ever and ever
that's what the big money is they want
to be able to dose people over and over
and over keep them alive for a couple
years at least on all the drugs that's
the incentive for making money think it
through a little bit it's sad but it's
reality if you found the cure for cancer
boom now what now you're not doing
nothing and you're out of business
too
[Music]
isn't it sad that all these years later
we're now 15 16 17 years later and it's
deja vu all over again this is all a reh
cash of what they did in the '90s we
worked night and day to organize the
patients without this
treatment my son will die to get the
Congressional hearings underway out of
52 cases of that disease ever no one
died cancer-free just Chrissy so she
didn't die of a terminal illness she
died because there's a government
institution that disseminates false
information and is not looking out for
the welfare of the people if it weren't
for the efforts of our group and all of
the patients who contributed their time
their effort and their money Dr binski
might not have survived the trial and he
would be rotting away in a jail cell
today there's got to be a way to level
the playing field that does not favor
the mercs and the Bristol Meyers and the
large drug companies there should be a
system developed where we can encourage
uh um uh Innovative uh research that's
being done by the sole practitioner the
sole researcher that's the problem let's
look at Medical breakthroughs in 1920
Banting in best or Banting up in Canada
had discovered insulin and had this idea
that if insulin could be given to a
patient with diabetes type 1 diabetes it
would cure the condition within 2
years uh Eli Lily had insulin in
drugstores let's skip another 20 years
pneumonia was a Scourge until Fleming
discovered
penicillin now penicillin was used
pneumonia left we haven't had a medical
breakthrough in 50 years because Today
medical breakthroughs put at risk the
entire Financial
underpinnings if you have medical
breakthroughs that
replace therapy that are
failing then the profits and the and the
cash flow of those therapies that are
failing is lost and lost forever so that
is the biggest barrier to brazinski or
anybody else that brings on a therapy
that is superior to what is done today
hence we haven't had any major medical
breakthroughs uh for the last 50 years
so what do we have we we have this
Outreach of
awareness we got people running around
with all kinds of colored ribbons saying
that I am aware of breast cancer we got
football players wearing pink shoelaces
increasing awareness of breast cancer
there was no movement to increase the
awareness of diabetes there was no
movement to increase the awareness of
pneumonia there is no need for any
movement to increase your awareness of
any disease you got a serious disease in
in your culture you are aware of it and
what awareness doesn't do it doesn't
cure the
disease it's not going to lead to the
Cure because today virtually every
serious disease has a huge vested
interest in the therapies that people
are paying money for that
fail so everything is locked but you you
come across with something that cures
cancer
[Music]
while I was entering the MRI machine I
was made aware that the FDA entered
bazin's Clinic one day prior if the
results of this FDA visit ends badly and
my cancer returns I might not get the
option of Ever Getting Antonio plastor
again and I'm going to talk you through
the first scan that I saw and the last
scin that you're are going to see now
thank you what we see is uh that lesion
is markedly reduced in size rim
enhancement has gone as well shows that
lur has been really responding well to
treatment okay there is no sign of
residual disease at all that's
great I can't imagine a world where
other people will not have the privilege
that I have had the privilege to have
their life saved by a new technology
that can cure cancer is terrified
[Music]
thing
we would like to publish the our data in
this randomized study to the medical
journal I hope the uh big medical
journal will accept the our experience
the our we we have done in the past 27
years yeah I hope I don't know the big
general
or this thing is bigger to than
brazinski because it represents is a
true
breakthrough where Generations from
separated from us 30 40 years if binski
was liberated or if his if his therapy
were liberated Generations separated
won't be thinking about cancer we're not
thinking about pneumonia and we're not
thinking about diabetes so they will not
be thinking about cancer can you imagine
a society where women are not terrified
by mammograms and men are not kind of
semi raped with all this prostate stuff
can you think of of a culture living
without this Perpetual fear of cancer
that's what
brazinsky Discovery
offers the concept of antias treatment
has not easily
accepted in general meaning but you know
if you open them your mind and uh if you
you willing to accept the any concept
coming in just think about
the the benefit for the patient that's
all that's the whole purpose of the
medicine
there I think it is only human to want
to seek treatment for a disease that is
considered to be almost universally
fatal we can obviously only offer the
treatment that we ourselves
offer but I'm always pleased if a
patient's treatment is going
successfully and that their disease is
either remitting or go into
remission for whatever
reason always correct you think of
anything excuse me anything else I would
like to yeah anything else you want to
say all right not with cameras running
okay cool turn everything off you turn
everything off and then I'll speak to
you okay cool